foreign
what is going on I just got out of a
screening of Ghostbusters afterlife here
in Singapore and I cannot wipe this
smile off my face
I really enjoyed this film yeah I am a
fan of the 1984-1989 Ghostbusters okay I
watched the 84 and 89 in the cinemas I
remember in 84 when I went to the cinema
and I saw it for the first time I loved
that film and I used to watch it so many
times on VHS
and this has so much that DNA in it
Jason Reitman has done such an amazing
job paying homage to his father's iconic
film but at the same time putting his
own fingerprints in this film really
tapping into the relationships and to
the family bonding but the same time
giving the fans yes there's fan service
but it's done so Tastefully so
respectfully that you're going to smile
when you see it you're gonna laugh
you're gonna chuckle you're gonna go
thank you for doing that because that's
something we need because you know a lot
of the times when they try to like
rehash older films or they want to
remake or reboot it some com some movie
studios don't necessarily always respect
the older material is as good as they
could
but they did it here oh man did they do
it it is uh I really really enjoyed this
film now as you can tell by the trailers
I'm not going to give away the story but
I'll just talk about what's in the
trailers yes it's set in an older Town
Egon spanglers the grandkids his
daughter are going to his house of
course the late Harold Ramis is no
longer with us and obviously things are
happening in this town now of course we
see the trailers Ecto ones there proton
packs you know they've got it all there
and you're probably thinking how are
these kids doing all this stuff what's
going on here how how is this all coming
together is it just to be like a reboot
with kids and the original characters
are just being thrown to the side no not
at all so much respect is given to the
original Ghostbuster films
so much guys do not be worried about
that at all it is ah I mean
okay I'm going to tell you this let's go
let's talk about the kids first Mckenna
Grace
is phenomenal in this film now she is
the young girl that looks like a mini
Egon Spangler and in a lot of ways she
is and within the first five to ten
minutes you are just on her journey this
movie is really about her journey for
the most part for the most part but
there's also Carrie Coons who plays her
mother it's also about her it's also
about the brother it's about his them
fitting into this small town how things
are going about what's going on with
their family then of course ghosts come
into play and everything else Paul Rudd
by the way is fantastic in this film
he's great he fits right into it you're
gonna know right away when it happens
and you're going to love it but it's
done so well it reminds me okay if
there's two movies this film reminds me
of
it's Ghostbusters 84 because a lot of
the storyline is taken right from 84. a
lot of it okay from the gatekeeper to
Gozer the key master that's all there
right it's all there right but also
reminds me of Goonies
it reminds me a lot of Goonies
especially with the kids and I loved
Goonies growing up I don't know about
you guys but I loved it so you take
these two iconic films
and you put it into one
and that is essentially afterlife
but
I know a lot of you can ask me or I want
to ask me here what about the original
cast
I'm not going to say a word about that
I will just tell you
it's done with so much respect
and I'm getting a little teary-eyed
because I was a big fan of the 84 and 89
films but it was
guys you're gonna love it that's all I'm
gonna say you're going to love it you're
gonna have a laugh you're gonna have a
great time with this I say no more
just go into this film
and enjoy it and I'm glad they made this
movie
I'm glad they made it now there's a lot
of the Great Performances in this
there's a lot of cameos in this film
that you're not expecting and I'm not
talking about original cast other actors
because we know when Jason Reitman and
you got Ghostbusters comes into play
You're Gonna Be You know when you look
at the cast list you can be like whoa
that person's that oh what it's quite
it's cool it's very very cool and by the
way there are two post-credit scenes
okay one right after the film ends and
then one at the very end of all the
credits stay for them stay for them it's
nothing to do with like going into some
Multiverse stuff okay that's none of
that stuff I know we're kind of
programmed for that when we talk about
you know post credit scenes but you're
gonna love it you are going to love it
anyway those are my thoughts on the film
The Originals right
is right and I'll chat to you soon take
care